how's it feel
really really happy thank you so surreal
this long journey Ends Tonight with an
Oscar win
how are you gonna celebrate look I'm
here with my family and friends yes I
have a whole group of friends who are so
happy for me so we are going to
celebrate and stuff dance the night away
what would you remember most about
tonight
when they called my name
Jamie Lee Curtis and Jamie Lee Curtis
and Daniels 7 out of 11.
what does it mean to be the first Asian
performer to win best actress at the
Oscars
it's a historical win and um
well just hope that I'm not the last
this is just the beginning
congratulations
yes it looks good on you that's a good
accessory Michelle I love it enjoy
tonight
[Music]